I know these rules can feel constraining
but remember the point of this course is
to learn how to write clearly and
persuasively think about that think
about the truth of your argument
[Music]
you're an amazing personality
I couldn't ask for a more incredible
daughter
are you actually trying to parent me
right now
who would want me
you don't stay in touch with Mom she
really only tells me things about you
why
because that's all I want to know about
why'd you gain all that weight someone
close to me passed away and it had an
effect on me you haven't seen her since
she was eight years old and you're gonna
reconnect with her sorry I don't like
this this isn't a good idea I'm sorry
I'm sorry right into you I swear to God
go ahead What's it gonna do my internal
organs are two feet in at least
why do you suddenly need to see her so
bad why now
I'm worried that she's forgotten what an
amazing person she is
I need to know that she's gonna have a
decent life where she cares about people
and it's just gonna be okay
I need I need to know that I
that I want
what the right was my life
[Music]